Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu unserer kleinen welt ich bin's tim,
und ja auch so aus dem affekt heraus hier letzte woche angefangen mal das corona lok down thema aufzugreifen ohne genau zu wissen wohin uns die reise führt das wissen wir ja in gewisser hinsicht alle gerade selber nicht
und das ist auch gut so das muss man akzeptieren und irgendwie versuchen damit klarzukommen,
gab ganz interessante rückmeldungen zur letzten sendung da waren wir auch gleich noch mal drauf eingehen jetzt erstmal wichtig wen habe ich denn jetzt noch dabei,
ich habe dabei den rudi hallo rudi.
Hallo tim.
So für die leute die den anderen kanal nicht kennen wir sind seit jahren schon zusammen mit vielen anderen in der freakshow gemeinsam,
und reden dann normalerweise über die lust weiten des einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts was uns so technisch und sonst wie gesellschaft technisch auch interessiert,
stellt sich natürlich die frage warum quatsch ich jetzt mit dir kurz gesagt du bist betroffen.
Zumindest nehme ich es schwer an es gibt keine harten beweise.
Ja aber es gibt eine harte indizien.
Es getan indizien ja man hört sie schon.
Ja da hört man sie auch schon genau also macht ganz so den eindruck als ob du dir den virus irgendwo eingefangen hast.
Ja und es ist völlig unklar wo also das ist also zumindest wenn es der virus ist ne also das muss ich immer wieder dazu sagen ich behaupte jetzt nicht dass ich mit hundertprozentiger sicherheit wüsste dass ich das virus habe
aber irgendwie passt das alles ein bisschen zu gut.
Spricht was eigentlich alle symptome über die gemeinhin so gerade diskutiert wird und ja.
Alles außer fieber komischerweise.
Achso ok dann bist du vielleicht.
Also ich habe diverse male gemessen ich habe hier auch mit zwei unterschiedlichen fieberthermometer gemessen eins ist so ein infrarot in ihr so so ein orthese meter und das andere ist ein klassisches zum irgendwo reinstecken,
und die haben immer relativ auf die nachkommastelle gleiche zahlen ausgespuckt aber halt nie in der höhe dass man sagen würde fieber.
Und du fühlst dich auch nicht unbedingt jetzt besonders fiebrig.
Überhaupt.
Aber das ist ja eigentlich schon so ein primär indikator mit dem eigentlich so die leute aus der masse rausgezogen werden.
Ja naja obwohl man liest gemeinhin das fieber sehr häufig wäre.
Ja ja es ist häufig wenn ich vielleicht sogar glaube ich das häufigste symptom zusammen mit trockener husten.
Ja den habe ich und zwar schon sehr lange.
Genau und du hast auch atmung probleme.
Ja genau also seit heute vielleicht ein anfang gestern wird's langsam besser,
aber ich habe das schon sehr lange also ich weiß nicht ob wir ob wir direkt schon auf die die timeline eingehen wollen du wolltest aber erst auf den auf die letzte sendung noch eingehen.
Genau das kann man ja vielleicht mal machen nur um das erstmal so zu zu klären warum wir jetzt hier eigentlich miteinander quatschen aber du hast sozusagen auch die sendung gehört mit pavel die ich gemacht hab.
Und ich habe sie mir auch noch ein zweites mal angehört und,
ich persönlich fand das fast schon visionär was pavel gesagt hat weil einerseits.
Ist halt alles eingetroffen und andererseits halt auch mit wie soll ich sagen mit hoher vitalität also halt auch,
genau das was er gesagt hat das ist das finde ich schon das fand ich schon sehr spannend wobei ich auch schon beim ersten hören das gefühl hatte ja das klingt zwar alles ein bisschen dramatisch was er erzählt aber irgendwie hat er ja doch recht.
Es gab erschreckend viel
rückmeldungen kritischer natur also das hat mich ein bisschen überrascht erstmal die geschwindigkeit also es gab
gut vielleicht magst manche leute gegeben haben die schlicht mit seiner sprechweise nicht so richtig klar kommen dafür habe ich ein gewisses verständnis aber ich denke mal es lohnt sich sehr zuzuhören
aber ich würde sagen es gab halt einerseits so ein bisschen kritik in die richtung,
das wäre ja alles jetzt viel zu apokalyptisch und überhaupt und man kann ja nicht hier einfach mit irgendwelchen zahlen kommen die nicht vom robert koch institut
hoch heilig abgesegnet sind und was erlaube pavel selber seine eigenen formeln aufzustellen und einfach mal diese prinz diese veröffentlichten prinzipien nach zurechnen,
und dann gab es halt noch ein bisschen manöverkritik in die richtung auf so ein paar details wie zum beispiel das,
er hat er hat gesagt da okay medikamente mit antiviralen medikamenten wird experimentiert etcetera,
dafür hatte ich dann zum zeitpunkt der veröffentlichung noch nicht alle links in der sendung die habe ich mittlerweile nachgetragen wo das.
Zu lesen ist ja wie das immer so ist mit informationen aus dem internet man muss sich da
kann immer so sein kann kann auch anders sein sind jetzt auch nicht die experten,
haben wir eigentlich auch von anfang an gesagt aber es es gab auf jeden fall ein bisschen aufregung aber du hast ja die zahlen jetzt auch nochmal genauer angeschaut.
Naja was heißt genauer angeschaut hat sich das heute noch mal gehört hab viel mehr halt auf dass pavel sowas sagte so,
jetzt parat frisiert er rechnet damit dass wir in zwei bis drei wochen italienische verhältnisse haben also zwölftausend fälle.
Dies zu dem zeitpunkt waren und.
In italien genau und dann dachte ich mir so zwölftausend die zahl hast du doch heute schon irgendwo gelesen und siehe da tatsächlich zwölftausend fälle ist halt die offizielle zahl des robert koch instituts von heute
dazu muss man vielleicht nochmal dazu sagen wir haben jetzt den neunzehnten märz,
donnerstag neunzehnter märz ist wichtig dazu zu sagen das heißt die italienischen verhältnisse von vor sechs tagen oder sieben tagen wenn ihr das aufgenommen hat,
die sind jetzt in einer woche erreicht und nicht in zwei bis drei wochen insofern hat pavel an der stelle eher noch,
hat er noch vorsichtig geschätzt.
Ja also er hat ja gar nicht geschätzt er hat alle einfach mal nachgerechnet so nach nach diesem ganzen kurven verteilung prinzipien die,
quasi so gemeinde zitiert und dargelegt worden wie sich das verhält mit dieser s-kurve etcetera und es ist halt auch generell so dass man eben,
da sehr viel also es gibt da keine genauigkeit aus verschiedenen gründen,
einerseits gibt's halt keine genauigkeit weil eben auch diese ganzen zahlen ja nicht genau sind deutschland mag viel mehr fälle haben als die die wir jetzt haben weil das sind ja nur die die getestet wurden aber es ist ja nicht so dass jeder getestet wird es ist kein abbild,
der realität.
Aber noch reden wir ja nur von getesteten fällen das waren damals in italien ja auch nur getestete fälle,
das war ja auch klar dass die dunkelziffer in italien sehr hoch ist,
ob sie in deutschland jetzt zu dem zeitpunkt sehr hoch ist oder nicht ist nicht klar ich persönlich würde eher in richtung höhere dunkelziffer schätzen zu der ich dann auch gehöre ich bin dunkelziffer.
Ja
Aber aber wenn man sich den verlauf seit anfang märz anguckt der zahlen in deutschland dann ist es ungefähr das was ich als lehrer in der schule an die tafel zeichnen würde wenn ich den schülern erklären wollte was ein experiment kurve ist.
Und zwar wirklich butter sanft und schön geht die da hoch also das ist irgendwie das das kann man halt nicht wegdiskutieren.
Ja das stimmt,
dann ich hab auch nochmal reingehört und es gab auch noch ein paar andere ansagen also das sozusagen schul-und geschäftsschluss
eigentlich ist auch bald mal anstehen würden ne wie gesagt das weiß genau vor einer woche dass wir gesprochen haben das war der donnerstag dann gibt es ja alles ganz schnell um,
und siehe da,
schon ein paar tage später war die schulschließungen im prinzip deutschlandweit verfügt und spätestens am montag mittag war es dann auch soweit,
und jetzt letzte verschärfung der situation ist glaube ich dass jetzt auch alle geschäfte zu machen ich bin jetzt gerade nicht ganz so sicher
wie das jetzt heute gelaufen ist zumindest jetzt hier in berlin,
sind glaube ich die normalen geschäfte jetzt auch zu die restaurants weiß ich nicht mehr so ganz genau ob die noch eine öffnungsgesetz haben oder nicht.
Irgendwas war von restaurants dürfen ob sex zu abends offen haben oder.
Ja das war aber schon vor ein paar tagen so genau also.
Ok also ich hab's nicht so richtig verfolgt ich halte es persönlich auch nicht wirklich für sinnvoll zumindest lebensmittelgeschäfte und und ähnliches zu schließen aber.
Das steht ja auch nicht zur disposition also lebensmittelgeschäfte definitiv supermärkte etcetera apotheken ärzte natürlich noch so ein paar andere grundversorgung sachen auch reinigung und zwar es gibt also eine ganze reihe von,
versorgungslücke die einfach definitiv offen bleiben werden nur gibt's halt jetzt gerade keinen grund schuhe kaufen zu gehen.
Na ja das wär jetzt auch mein beispiel gewesen zu einer sportshow boutique oder ein schmuck geschäft ist vielleicht jetzt muss jetzt nicht offen sein.
Genau also es gibt auf der einen seite gibt's den versorgungsbedarf leute müssen sich natürlich mit dem was nötig ist und eindecken können und vor allem wenn es halt nicht verfügbar ist was dann auch so potenziell zu,
würde ich sagen jetzt riot führt aber wo die leute dann dann das auch ignorieren würden und versuchen würden auf anderem wege dessen habhaft zu werden aber alles was er mal purer luxus ist das kann halt jetzt mal weg
und ja das ist sozusagen der stand an dem wir jetzt sind und jetzt müssen wir eigentlich nur noch schauen.
Sich jetzt durch diese neue situation eine verbesserung einstellen wird und das wird noch dauern.
Ja naja also ich meine pavel meinte sowas seine kurven würden davon ausgehen dass tatsächlich die wende in den zahlen erst nach zwei wochen oder so kommen
weil die fallzahlen ja entsprechend durchlaufen und wenn man dann guckt was für eine steigerungskurve die diese experimental kurve momentan hat,
dann,
sind wir in zwei wochen wahrscheinlich über na ja knapp knapp an den an den hunderttausend dran fallzahlen bevor es dann anfängt weniger zu werden also das finde ich schon drastisch,
aber naja das werden wir sehen.
Robert koch institut hatte auch vor einer woche noch die aussage die gefährdung wäre mild was merkwürdiges wort ist in dem zusammenhang mittlerweile sind wir auf hoch.
So mein mein meine interpretation der lage war dass das robert koch institut sich ein bisschen zu lange die der illusion hingegeben hat dass wir das in deutschland unter kontrolle hätten.
Weil ja,
die leute an der charité haben den test entwickelt der deutschland in die lage versetzt hat sehr viel zu testen und und auch sehr viele ansteckungen nachzuvollziehen,
das hat glaube ich so ein falschen eindruck der wir haben die sache im griff,
hervorgerufen vor allen dingen weil alle nachvollziehbaren ketten da hat man die leute isoliert dann sind die leute dem kind die verbreitung nicht weiter und dann haben sich halt alle irgendwie so das gefühl gehabt,
ja ok wir haben das im griff weil wir alle bekannten übertragungsrate ausgeschlossen haben,
aber die dunkelziffer zu dem zeitpunkt war wahrscheinlich schon relativ hoch,
und die verbreitung der dunkelziffer ist wurde glaube ich komplett unterschätzt was das bedeutet dass das sich halt leute anstecken ohne dass man weiß dass es sich anstecken,
dann wurde ja auch sehr stark die politik gefahren gehen wir später noch drauf ein dass du einen test auch nur dann bekommst wenn du tatsächlich mehr oder weniger dich angesteckt haben kannst,
an bekannten fällen.
Einfach weil die die die die test kapazität,
immer noch nicht da ist wo man sie vielleicht gerne hätte also was nicht südkorea schafft es mittlerweile irgendwie zweihunderttausend test pro tag durchzuführen und wir sind vielleicht mal gerade bei der hälfte pro woche,
das war schon ganz andere dimension pflicht weil einfach nicht genug labor kapazität verfügbar ist.
Woran es genau liegt sei jetzt mal dahingestellt ob wir das noch gefixt kriegen sei auch dahingestellt inzwischen habe ich das gefühl nein wir werden es nicht hin hinkriegen,
wir können uns jetzt eigentlich nur noch überlegen die kapazitäten die wir haben,
machen wir für fälle wo es um leben und tod geht oder um pflegepersonal und es wäre meiner meinung nach inzwischen meiner meinung nach auch okay.
Da war ich vor einer woche noch anderer meinung,
also ich meine wir haben es nicht geschafft die entsprechenden kapazitäten aufzubauen die werden auch nicht mehr kommen wenn er nicht ein deutlich einfacher test kommt,
den man mehr oder weniger im blister pack in in der drogerie kaufen kann dann war's das.
Da gibt es zumindest hoffnung also,
wie wie so viele andere auch sollte man an dieser nochmal an der stelle nochmal erwähnen es gibt nach wie vor diesen hochinteressanten täglichen update oder werk tägliches update podcast denn in der eins info losgetreten hat,
corona virus podcast mit dem chef der biologie an der charité dem christian trosten und.
Die leute die den derzeitigen test quasi entwickelt haben.
Genau also die wirklich.
Denen ist er der chef.
Die quelle das heißt er hat.
Die quelle.
Hochgradig hochgradig einblick ist mal sehr interessant wie er so die dinge reflektiert wir auch so meldungen auf studien reflektiert wir auch vielleicht nicht unbedingt immer richtig liegt
oder zumindest ist auch noch andere meinungen geben kann es gab ja zum beispiel jetzt die sache mit dem mit dem e-book propheten unverträglichkeit die hat ja so ein bisschen in frage gestellt die who,
tut es derzeit nicht schwierig zu sagen ob das jetzt sozusagen gilt oder nicht gilt aber da kriegt man auf jeden fall auch ganz interessante informationen in bezug auf,
okay wie ist denn das jetzt eigentlich mit den test hat ja jetzt gerade glaube ich nicht nehmen gestrigen sendung das,
es neue ansätze gäbe so ein schnelltest zu entwickeln,
es schwappen jetzt spart mir jetzt gerade zwar erste tests wohl auch schon in die apotheken oder versuchen zumindest bei uns in der apotheken zu landen die aus china kommt,
allerdings sind das tests auf gebildete antikörper.
Richtig antikörper tests.
Und die helfen nur insofern also sie könnten auch ganz praktisch sein weil die eigentlich nur sagen ob man den virus schon mal gehabt hat.
Ja ja.
Aber man kriegt ihn halt nicht rechtzeitig weil wenn die krankheit ausbricht zu dem zeitpunkt sind diese antikörper halt auch noch nicht so richtig gebildet das heißt man,
kann sozusagen nicht leute testen kriegt irgendein ergebnis und weiß okay alles klar bei dir könnte es jetzt gleich losgehen dich die schienen wir jetzt mal weg.
Interessant fand ich in dem zusammenhang dass er meinte die fouls positive rate ist extrem niedrig bei diesem test,
also leute kriegen nicht angezeigt sie hätten corona wenn sie's gar nicht haben die fouls negative rate ist aber relativ hoch und zwar ein drittel.
Also bestimmte nicht gesehen werden.
Das heißt ein drittel der leute bekommen kein positiven test obwohl sie hinkriegen müssten,
das fand ich das fand ich interessant interessantes detail dadran sollte uns aber alle nicht daran hindern diese tests tatsächlich einzusetzen meiner meinung nach.
Wenn sie überhaupt erstmal bereit verfügbar wären.
Na ich denke mal ich denke mal dass die chinesen irgendwo auch da liefern werden also dinge produzieren das können die.
Ja das stimmt aber eigentlich geht es halt um um einen test der ihm jetzt wirklich diesen relativ langsamen aktuellen pc test den halt
die psychologie dort entwickelt hat ablöst damit es halt schneller gehen kann weil derzeit bedeutet testen immer abstrich nehmen probe ins labor labor muss dran arbeiten
und irgendwie aus dem labor raus es gibt halt nicht so einen abstrich irgendwie und ich berühre das mit so einem kleinen papierchen und dann wird es irgendwie grün oder blau und dann weiß ich bescheid,
an sowas wird gearbeitet,
wann es kommt wissen wir nicht aber das wäre sozusagen dann erst so der durchbruch wenn man wenn man sowas hätte und b auch in entsprechenden mengen diskutieren könnte und theoretisch sozusagen jeder oder zumindest sehr viel mehr leute in der lage werden den,
anzuwenden solange solange bleibt halt alles ein wenig im dunkeln.
Das wird sich auch bis dahin nicht ändern glaube ich also.
Gut was ich was sich geändert hat ist natürlich hier das leben so also man merkt schon so richtig man hört
die vögel zwitschern hier in berlin und irgendwie deutlich weniger verkehr und deutlich weniger leute auf den straßen man hat so ein bisschen was von weihnachten.
Um es mal positiv zu formulieren.
Ja
Du dich mit der aussicht gesuchte geschenke zu bekommen natürlich ne.
Ist die ruhe nicht schon an sich.
Wobei die kinder also die kinder werden jetzt teilweise schon beschenkt weil jetzt alle ja sozusagen in die lage versetzt werden müssen
videotelefonie zu betreiben und wer sozusagen jetzt noch kein smartphone hatte hat jetzt spätestens eins
überhaupt finde ich das ganz interessant wie jetzt die digitalisierung auf einmal entdeckt wird in deutschland home-office.
Ja soweit muss es kommen soweit muss es.
Ja soweit musste es erst kommen dass es dass es wirklich traurig in gewisser hinsicht aber immerhin also wenn das jetzt nicht,
geschnallt hätten dann wäre irgendwie gar nichts mehr zu holen also das ist so ein bisschen auch das,
der der der zeit also vor zehn jahren hätte das noch ganz anders ausgesehen da hätten wir nicht so viele möglichkeiten gehabt dem herr zu werden,
andererseits haben wir natürlich auch das problem wieder mit fake news etcetera darauf will ich jetzt gar nicht eingehen und ich will euch jetzt gar nicht die ganze digitalisierung debatte losreden aber ich denke uns ist halt schon klar so
jetzt machen halt viele auf und viele unternehmen merken halt auch so wenn jetzt alle unsere mitarbeiter zu hause sind und von außen zugreifen wollen dann reicht ja unsere internetanschluss überhaupt nicht,
so und ich weine und lache gleichzeitig ein wenig in mich hinein.
Auch auch bei uns in der firma wurde kurzfristig die vpn kapazität erhöht.
Weil es einfach,
allein so diese ganzen diskussionen immer mit ja wozu brauchst du denn so viel upload und so wer will denn wer braucht ein schnelles netz und und so weiter,
ja leute jetzt wenn es jetzt noch nicht gemerkt habt dann werdet ihr es nie merken aber jetzt sehen wir wofür man schnelles netz braucht ja das ist das ist einfach wichtig,
an der stelle aber ich höre ich höre auch schon wieder auf weil das ja alles keinen sinn,
hört aber auch keiner zu gut erzählt euch jetzt mal ein bisschen wie es dir ergangen ist vielleicht das klima nochmal vorweg ja also das letzte mal schon gegeben habe also erstens wir sind hier keine experten ja wir wir versuchen auch keinen,
keine keine handlungsvorschlag haben zu machen oder so und wir versuchen wir behaupten auch nicht hier in irgendeiner form die wahrheit zu sprechen ja.
Auf keinen fall.
Aber trotzdem wollen wir sozusagen
futter futter liefern zum mitdenken denn darum geht es ja einfach ne wir wollen einfach ein bisschen unseren unseren geist hier spielen lassen und ihr könnt wenn ihr zuhört
euren geist mitspielen lassen und ihr müsst nicht unbedingt immer allzu denselben schlüssel kommen ja und wenn ihr zur anderen schüssen kommen könnt ihr uns das auch gerne in den kommentaren
mitteilen wie gesagt,
biologische epidemiologische medizinische und katastrophen technische gesellschaftliche politische informationen gibt es massenhaft da draußen es gibt finde ich,
medienverhalten sich sehr gut soweit man merkt eine anstrengung meine.
Bei manchen zumindest.
So sogar die kriminellen helfen ja jetzt mit ne also gibt's ja so die ersten gruppen die gesagt haben sie hören jetzt mal auf die die gesundheitsministerium anzugreifen,
hurra selbst den geht der arsch auf grundeis richtig so.
Oh man wird selbst die kriminal- kriminellen irgendwie dann schon mitleid haben.
Ja so aber gut also das jetzt mal ich hoffe dass jetzt deutlich genug gesagt zu haben aber wir machen hier einfach begleitprogramm.
Genau genau also ich kann mal ich kann mal so meine journey schildern nochmal zur erinnerung wir haben heute den neunzehnten märz los geht's bei mir im am sechsten märz das war ein freitag,
der ist jetzt ungefähr zweihundert zwei wochen ja knappe knappe zwei wochen her.
Da ist mir das erste mal aufgefallen dass ich so ein bisschen husten habe,
das war mir so ein bisschen peinlich auch weil alle ja irgendwie immer gesagt haben zu ja und hier und husten und corona und so weiter und dann habe ich immer versucht nicht zu husten weil irgendwie,
denkt man so so dann gucken die leute blöd und so,
jetzt ist es so dass ich am sechsten märz an diesem freitag war ich abends noch bei einer chorprobe und dann hatten wir samstag sonntag
probe-wochenende mit dem chor und da hatte ich dann so insgesamt sagen wir mal mit zwanzig personen relativ eng in kontakt.
Was natürlich total doof ist ich bin mir nicht sicher wahrscheinlich habe ich keinen angesteckt aber mal sehen.
Oder das ist der da geholt oder meinst du da war schon vorbei weil da hast du schon symptome gehabt oder wie.
So kam es mir vor also es ist jetzt ein bisschen natürlich in der erinnerung ein bisschen trübe ich kann das jetzt nicht mehr mit hundertprozentiger,
wahrscheinlichkeit sagen aber ich würde mal sagen dass ich das da schon hatte vielleicht war es auch einfach nur so ein husten keine ahnung ich weiß es nicht.
Also acht tage neun tage vorher saßen wir hier noch zusammen in der metaebene,
von daher hoffe ich dass es dir danach kommt angefangen hast.
Naja nun also auf jeden fall an dem darauffolgenden montag,
hatte ich dann schon so ein bisschen so ein fühle mich nicht so bin aber trotzdem ins büro gegangen,
weil irgendwie weiß ich nicht so was es gibt so so diese wann ist der schwellenwert erreicht wo du dich so fühlst dass du nicht mehr ins büro gehst das ist immer eine extrem schwierige entscheidung finde ich.
Man will ja auch jetzt nicht als der hub honda dastehen oder sonstige wie oder keine ahnung auf jeden fall dienstag war es dann soweit dass ich das erste mal das gefühl hatte sagt nee.
Schon mal besser.
Mir ging's schon mal besser so und dann bin ich früh kurz nach mittag früher nachmittag bin ich nach hause gegangen.
Also am zehnten märz ne.
Am zehnten märz genau dienstag zehnter märz und da gab's bei uns in der kantine gab's fischsuppe das muss man jetzt nochmal dazu sagen ich hab also fischsuppe gegessen das ist ja sowieso irgendwie so ein schwieriges thema.
Ja
Und deswegen habe ich dann als ich zu hause war uns mich wie soll ich sagen darm tätig mit kalz maßig komplett zerrissen hat,
dachte ich mir so naja wird vielleicht dich fischsuppe gewesen sein weißt du nie so kantine und warm halten und keine ahnung,
aber ich hatte halt trotzdem diesen trockenen husten und diesen durchfall und dann am nächsten tag den den den mittwoch.
Gucken wir mal am mittwoch der elfte da bin ich aufgewacht mit.
Mit so einem gefühl als hätte ich einen riesigen stein in den bronchien ne also so dieses gefühl ich kriege nicht
wirklich gut luft weil da ist irgendwie irgendjemand hat von innen die lunge mit teer angemalt oder so also das war richtig richtig unangenehm
bin hier im haus zwei mal die treppe rauf und runter und stand dann oben hechelnd und hab kaum noch luft gekriegt sowas hab ich ehrlich gesagt noch nie erlebt.
Ein haus was du ja derzeit alleine bewohnst also da hast du sozusagen niemand den du jetzt gerade anstecken kannst.
Und dann ging es los dann hab ich die diversen hotlines durchprobiert,
war zuerst bei der corona hotline des weiß ich nicht ist dass der senat oder das gesundheitsamt oder so auf jeden fall so ein berliner ding neunzig achtundzwanzig achtundzwanzig achtundzwanzig keine ahnung dies,
geistert auch manchmal so durch die presse,
und hab da einfach mal nachgefragt hier was denn ist und da und so weiter und dann haben die mehr oder weniger halt die damals noch gültigen empfehlungen des robert-koch-instituts abgefragt hatte ich direkten kontakt zu,
einer risikogruppe oder war ich im ausland in oder in einem risikobereich oder hatte ich kontakt zu einer bestätigten fall.
Und alle diese dinge musste ich natürlich verneinen also was heißt natürlich also musste ich verneint weil hatte ich nicht.
Also man hat natürlich wenn man in berlin lebt sehr viel kontakt zu anderen leuten.
Supermarkt ja gut öffentlicher nahverkehr habe ich nicht gemacht in der zeit,
aber naja wie auch immer dann ist man mal hier in der kneipe da ist man mal da in der kneipe so dann war ich dann habe ich beim workshop klinikum angerufen die haben mich,
brust zurückgewiesen so nach der abwehr bezahlt denn das das müssten sie überhaupt erst mal mit ihrem arzt zu ihrer krankenkasse klären so und dann habe.
Was wenn du notfall hast.
Weil ich einen test wollte ich wollte vor allen dingen erst.
Achso ok wenn dir ging es jetzt schon explizit um testet bis jetzt nicht meine bist du denn beim arzt vorstellig geworden oder du hast einfach gedacht klingt jetzt schon nach corona du läufst jetzt nicht noch irgendwohin wo jemand anstecken kannst.
Genau das war so meine idee so deswegen ich wollte halt mal wissen wie ist es mit dem test mir war es schon irgendwie klar ja ich muss dann wahrscheinlich auch eine krank schrift mir
besorgen aber ich hatte auch mit schon mit mit der,
geredet also der personalabteilung und die meinten ja wenn es nach korona klingt dann setzen wir dich jetzt mal zwei wochen auf home-office fertig,
komm bitte nicht mehr in die firma und ich so ja okay gut pferd dir warum nicht weil wir nicht,
jetzt lass mich überlegen wie jetzt ich bin mir nicht mehr so ganz genau wie sicher wie die spiele die entsprechenden,
die reihenfolge war dann habe ich noch bei der krankenkasse angerufen also irgendwie gibt's in krankenkassen notdienst oder irgendwie sowas und die meinten auch ich würde nicht die robert koch kriterien erfüllen,
und dann habe ich noch beim hausarzt angerufen und.
Ich weiß nicht ob's nur mir so geht aber immer wenn ich mit ärzten zu tun habe landet man ja erst bei der sprechstunden hilfe.
Und das ist jedes mal schwierig irgendwie,
also da wird man dann auch gerne mal brust zurückgewiesen es war dort auch so ne ich sollte nicht kommen ich würde diese fernmündlich klangschrift bekommen.
Das ist etwas was die ein paar tage vorher eingeführt haben der hausarzt kann also jemanden krank schreiben ohne dass er ihn gesehen hat.
Indem man einfach symptome abfragt sozusagen.
Da ist ja auch erstmal sinnvoll dass die ärzte und so weiter so und dann sagten sie da tests machen wir aber nicht,
und dann war ich im prinzip auch schon durch alles durch was man so anrufen kann ja und dann rief irgendwann,
nee,
die zurück nee die meinten dann hat sie irgendwie am computer nachgeguckt meinte meine krankenkassenkarte wäre nicht aktuell genug und sie bräuchten die doch und ob die jemand vorbeibringen könnte manch nee habe ich niemanden und dann bin ich halt hingefahren habe sie einen briefkasten geworfen.
Ja na ja was soll ich machen also.
Ja okay praktische lösung.
Ja da nochmal angerufen dass jetzt im briefkasten klickt also wenn die schlau warnt dann haben sie sind sie damit mit desinfektionsmittel rangegangen und so weiter keine ahnung.
Aber dass man einfach auch absurd dass man nicht einfach irgendeine andere identifizierung möglichkeit hat remote sozusagen ja egal anderes thema noch was.
Genau und dann war ich erstmal krank geschrieben und dann hat sich eine ganze weile nichts getan also nicht wirklich der durchfall ist ein bisschen besser geworden,
husten und bronchien sind ein bisschen schlechter geworden aber es ist dann irgendwie.
Mehr oder weniger den rest der woche und und so weiter.
Hat sich hat sich da nichts getan also es war stein stein in den bronchien bin hier teilweise echt außer atem gell geraten,
auch wenn ich mit leuten telefoniert hab also mir fällt es ja jetzt immer noch schwer jetzt so lange zu reden weil ich immer nicht so richtig luft kriege aber.
Na ja es wurde es wurde dann so ein bisschen,
bisschen schlechter ende letzter woche und aber nicht wirklich toll es hat sich irgendwie nicht bewegt so dann habe ich wann war denn das gestern.
Gestern nochmal bei einem anderen arzt angerufen weil klangschrift war ja dann vorbei,
hier in der gegend und dann habe ich den den fall geschildert und hab dann auch dazu gesagt ja hier es könnte corona sein ja ja kommen sie mal vorbei.
Für heute also einen termin gegeben und ich habe mir nichts dabei gedacht weil die waren da so fröhlich und haben hier termin gegeben und meint nicht soll vorbeikommen bin ich also heute zu dem arzt,
er hat den korona gehört nämlich direkt wieder rausgeschmissen.
Aber er hat doch corinna schon vorher gehört.
Keine ahnung das scheint irgendwie bei der bei der.
Also du hast schon.
Bei der sprechstunden hilfe ich habe explizit dazu gesagt dass es dieser virus sein könnte.
Ich habe nicht gesagt dass es ist sondern dass ich den verdacht habe keine ahnung vielleicht hat die das nicht gerafft was ich meine,
auf jeden fall hat mich der der arzt dann also auch ganz schön angemacht das wäre unverantwortlich und gehen sie mal schnell wieder raus sie haben hier nichts zu suchen und ich dachte nur so hey aber ich habe doch einen termin bekommen das ist so na ja.
Ja vor allem ist das du du bist sozusagen jetzt unverantwortlich weil du dir empfehlungen seiner sprechstunden hilfe gefolgt bist großartig.
Ja aber das müssen sie doch wissen es ist doch in allen medien und so naja gut und so als letztes kapitel bin ich heute noch auf etwas zu,
hingewiesen worden und zwar hat die charité jetzt so eine kleine website aufgemacht app dort scharia de auf wo man symptome abfragen kann lassen kann.
Und nach dem nach dem abfragen aller symptome kommt dann raus melden sie sich bitte melden sie sich bei der hotline der senatsgesundheitsverwaltung so heißt die also die die ich vor acht jahren vor acht tagen schon mal angerufen habe,
die mich abgewimmelt haben na gut dann werde ich das morgen mal versuchen ich werde dann auf twitter berichten wie es gelaufen ist,
ja das ist so ein bisschen meine meine story gewesen.
Also diese app ist eigentlich eine website sozusagen.
Das ist eigentlich eine webseite die nennt sich app aber es ist eine webseite.
Aber das ist so als mobile ist eigentlich nichts eigentlich nur wasser ist ein fragebogen sozusagen den hast du aus.
Das ist im prinzip ein fragebogen am ende des fragebogens bekommt man irgendwie naja ein riesen r code und ein naja.
Wenn ich das jetzt ich kann das mal hier mal kurz mal anklicken mit deinen daten so zack allein wohnen hatten wir schon,
medizinischen bereich tätig nein gemeinschaft sei richtung nein zack weiter rauchen sie.
Nein in den letzten vier wochen verreist nein hatten sie in kontakt nein.
Zwei bestätigten fallen also hat schon in.
Genau bestätigten fall aber auch nicht zu einem verdachtsfall.
Fall fieber nein.
Nein auch nicht in den letzten vier tagen nein schüttelfrost nein fühlen sich schlapp oder abgeschlagen ja da habe ich mal ja angekreuzt haben sie gliederschmerzen nein.
Haben sie anhaltenden husten ja haben sie schnupfen nein haben sie durchfall ja immer noch ein bisschen haben sie halsschmerzen ja.
Hatten sie kopfschmerzen ja zwar nur ein bisschen aber es war kopfschmerz,
sehr sehr selten kopfschmerzen aber mir fällt das auf wenn ich welche habe sind sie schneller außer atem als sonst ja definitiv.
Ja genau.
Haben sich die symptome in den letzten vierzehn tagen entwickelt ja.
Jetzt muss ich erstmal hier symptomen datum angeben seit sechsten märz ne richtig.
Symptom datum musste ich da keins angeben.
Fragt er mich seit wann haben sie die symptome bitte geben sie das datum an.
Achso ja okay kann sein.
Chronische lungen vorerkrankungen.
Diese ganzen erkrankungen alles nein und ich nehme auch nix.
Ok
Aber die die grippeimpfung die hatte ich.
Eine fett sucht bis nicht schwanger cortison auch nicht keine immunsuppressiva hast du dich gegen grippe impfen lassen,
ja ok.
Sehr schön habe ich dieses jahr vergessen und ich schäme mich ein bisschen dafür so melden sie sich steht hier melden sie sich okay.
Und dann meldest du dich dann morgen mal sozusagen.
Ich werde da morgen anrufen weil die haben jetzt glaube ich schon zu also diese,
na ich habe zwischendurch auch noch beim ärztlichen bereitschaftsdienst angerufen da kommt ein gefühlt,
halbstündiger text wird einem alles erzählt zum thema corona,
dinge die weiß ich nicht noch aktuell sind oder nicht mehr auf jeden fall also es sind nur fünf minuten das sind vielleicht nur drei minuten aber es kommt einem ewig vor und dann drückt man ein paar tasten und dann heißt alle leitungen sind belegt und schmeißen sie einen raus.
Okay also wenn du glück hast dann wirst du jetzt doch noch final endlich mal getestet werden und dann wissen wir mehr.
Mit ein bisschen glück ja aber ich glaub nicht mehr so richtig dran weil sich die situation.
Halt auch so entwickelt hat das jetzt wirklich auch zu viele leute getestet werden müssen,
und ich dann glaube ich auch nicht mehr priorität habe außerdem ist die sache jetzt durch also ich meine die ich war jetzt seit na dienstag letzter woche.
Mehr oder weniger in quarantäne.
Ja und alles was davor ist es ist halt auch schon gegessen jetzt klar man könnte die leute noch informieren hier von dann und dann hatten wir kontakt und ich hätte euch anstecken können.
Aber die leute haben inzwischen entweder selber symptome entwickelt und wissen was los ist oder halt naja egal.
Also wir sehen da ist noch einiges zu holen aber wenn's gut also positive zeit kann man feststellen also bis jetzt noch nicht verstorben so muss das jetzt auch keine.
Nein das wird auch nicht passieren also.
Komplikationen haben und bonus track du bist jetzt mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit dann auch immun wenn du es denn überhaupt hattest.
Und genau das ist nämlich der punkt warum ich das unter anderem auch wissen will weil wenn ich das hatte und dann im mund bin dann stellen sich halt manche dinge für mich anders da.
Also dann könnte ich dann könnte ich halt dinge tun die andere leute nicht tun können weil weil weil das risiko für sie ist also nicht dass ich jetzt auf irgendwie jetzt party machen will oder so aber,
halt vielleicht auch für andere leute einkaufen oder irgendwie sowas.
Genau weil das.
Mit wenn ich einen zettel hab hier ich hatte korona blablabla dann kann ich den auch irgendwo vorweisen wenn es tatsächlich zu einer zu einer ausgangssperre geht dann halte ich den polizist des vor die nase und sag hier.
Immun.
Und ich jetzt einkaufen für freunde.
Ja das ist eigentlich so eine immun armee die wir jetzt irgendwie bräuchten das das wäre in der tat gut ja und da muss ich auch sagen auch wenn ich jetzt keinen keinen bock habe oder schnappatmung zu leiden,
ja oder überhaupt nicht auch nur zu,
zu gefährden oder und damit natürlich dann auch erstmal andere mit zu gefährden ist es in gewisser hinsicht,
ganz erstrebenswert diese immunität zu haben also man will ja nicht das risiko eingehen weil man ja nicht weiß ob man nicht zu diesen ein zwei prozent gehören
die da eben besonders schlecht drauf reagieren vielleicht nicht unbedingt mit meinem meinem alter nicht unbedingt die kern risikogruppe aber,
ist jetzt auch nicht so dass es jetzt komplett spurlos an dir vorbeigeht und es gibt auch junge leute die das haben also es ist ja sozusagen,
sind nur andere wahrscheinlichkeiten aber es nicht ausgeschlossen.
Naja es stellt sich ja so da und die erfahrung habe ich halt auch gemacht ist halt luft kriegen das ist halt das eigentliche ding,
wenn man wenn man mit einer halbwegs guten lunge ausgestattet ist dann sollte sich das machen lassen,
also das ist so für leute die die halt sowieso schon lungenproblemen haben asthma und so weiter oder ab einer bestimmten ab einem bestimmten alter wo der kreislauf edel langsam labil wird,
da ist es halt schwierig weil der körper dann die belastung vielleicht nicht mitmacht.
Aber ich glaube ja ich glaube auch für dich ist das risiko jetzt nicht so riesig.
Das was man immer erst danach ja es ist ein ort.
Ja ja klar natürlich natürlich ich sag ja nur ich glaube wissen tue ich das nicht.
Gut.
Dann wissen wir ja zumindest jetzt woran du bist und wir werden dann mal nächste woche schauen wie sich das weiterentwickelt hat ne
was sind denn jetzt so deine erfahrungen aus deiner selbstgewählten
quarantäne die ja dann schon relativ umfangreich war ich meine du hast ja so richtig abgeschottet jetzt ne machst du irgendwie,
menschenseele von irgendeiner distanz aus groß.
Naja ich habe von einer guten freundin einkauf irgendwie vor die tür gestellt bekommen,
aber ansonsten nichts dazu kommt noch eine sache es gab in der zeit glaube ich was was in der zeit,
gab es einen artikel von einer forschungsgruppe aus dem ruhrgebiet glaube ich,
die also die ist das ehemalige team von droste der kam ja irgendwie aus dem ruhrgebiet,
die haben in der studie herausgefunden dass corona patienten auch unter geschmacks und geruchlos ewigkeit leiden.
Dass die also dass die also tatsächlich nicht so viel schmecken und nicht so viel riechen und nachdem ich das gelesen habe dachte ich mir so,
ach deshalb schmeckt das alles nicht also es ist,
ich dachte nur das ist so na ja die situation ist so scheiße und jetzt hast du halt auch keinen bock irgendwie was leckeres zu essen oder so ist alles irgendwie pfade oder so aber nachdem ich den artikel gelesen hab ist mir erst aufgefallen ja klar der tee schmeckt nicht,
der kaffee schmeckt nicht also meistens zumindest nicht also tee ist klar.
Schmeckt eh nicht oder was.
Ne aber na ja wenn du wenn du dir mal anguckst raucher trinken selten tee,
weil die halt die entsprechenden geschmacksnerven nicht haben weil sie ständig nikotin drauf liegt so und und bei mir ist es so ich trinke eigentlich relativ gerne tee und ich schmecke auch den unterschied zwischen verschiedenen sorten,
meistens ich trinke auch gerne kaffee,
allerdings jetzt nicht den ganz ganz harten ohne milch espresso nur sehr selten weil mir das zu heftig ist
inzwischen aber jetzt ist es halt so dass das mir selbst kaffee teilweise fade schmeckt und das ist schon irgendwie das schon strange,
und manche dinge schmecken auch einfach komisch und dann dachte ich mir so ja bist du umgezogen hast du deine gewürze nicht schmeckt halt ein bisschen anders und so aber das allein erklärt es dann doch noch nicht also es ist schon irgendwie.
Kann ich jedem nur empfehlen da zumindest mal drauf zu achten ob man dieses ob man das nachvollziehen kann dass dinge plötzlich anders schmecken und man kein bock mehr drauf hat weil es irgendwie pfade ist und so.
Okay naja also die die dinge weisen bei dir wirklich schon sehr dahin dass dass du da betroffen bist aber du hast wahrscheinlich auch nicht den hauch eine ahnung wo du es dir jetzt als einfangen können außer dieser chor situation vielleicht.
Na ja sagen wir mal so wer ist wir ich arbeite bei einer firma wo ungefähr sechshundert leute arbeiten wir sind über zwei standorte verteilt.
Eine internationale firma.
Ja wir hatten in der entsprechenden woche auch noch irgendwie besuch von,
von vertretern anderer firmen die von uns versuchen dinge zu verkaufen und so also dann
die sache mit dem chor und ich meine in berlin im supermarkt
also das ist schon irgendwie ja es gibt nichts offensichtliches was mir da einfällt aber es sind halt so viele sachen wo man so denkt so na ja es ist jetzt auch nicht an den haaren herbeigezogen,
ist ja jetzt nicht so als wär ich vorher schon vier wochen unter quarantäne gewesen und,
tritt es plötzlich auf sondern ein ganz normales großstädter leben geführt und da kann's halt schon mal passieren denke ich mir aber.
Eine gute erklärung habe ich nicht also das ganz klar.
Okay woher auch gut rudi sonst noch irgendwas aus deiner warte was so gerne mitteilen möchtest oder.
Also ich meine den trosten und seinen podcast haben wir jetzt schon erwähnt.
Kann man auch gerne nochmal machen.
Hört den trosten ansonsten in der financial times waren interessante kurven drin,
da hatten die mal die verläufe.
Sie hatten die verläufe übereinander gelegt ich glaube alles ab zehn fälle,
und das ist ganz interessant weil die weil die zahlen irgendwie wenn man die logarithmus aufträgt irgendwie alle übereinander liegen mehr oder weniger.
Also da gibt's halt so ein paar länder die biegen dann nach unten ab weil sie es in griff gekriegt haben aber das sind im wesentlichen ja nur china und und südkorea.
Und alle anderen haben es nicht im griff und gehen schön steil exponentiell nach oben ist es dass es interessant und erschreckend anzugucken und deutschland ist natürlich mittendrin also wir uns geht's da nicht viel anders,
ansonsten,
kurven von world of mieters die finde ich auch ganz spannend weil sie es einem relativ einfach machen die kurven einzelner länder einfach anzugucken,
wir sind bei denen bei deutschland nicht die robert koch zahlen sondern die von der morgenpost und die haben sie wiederum von ich habe da mal nachgeguckt.
Es gibt so ein ding so ein gitter pause tory das täglich gepflegt wird wo sie tatsächlich die ganzen daten reinkippen irgend so einer uni in in in amiland,
ich muss das jetzt selber nochmal anklicken und um das genau zu sehen wie das war.
Das fand ich das fand ich schon auch sehr spannend wie heißt das virus data reporter tory bei johns hopkins,
was auch immer wofür auch immer ihr steht aber die haben hier.
Center for science and engineering.
Ok also die tragen hier die daten zusammen ich nehme mal an dass man da auch relativ einfach seine eigenen,
kurven da zusammenbasteln kann aus den daten das fand ich das fand ich relativ schön so als tipp für alle die auch selber mal mit daten spielen wollen so pavel style.
Ja genau.
Ja dann gucken wir mal wie sich das jetzt entwickelt
todes zahlen steigen langsam in deutschland infektionen zahlen wie gesagt
werden zwar welche gemeldet sind so schon beunruhigend und sind mit sicherheit nicht ausreichend mindestens dich muss man jetzt noch glaube ich mit dazu zählen also immer alles plus eins.
Also in tote noch nicht.
Nein noch nicht nicht alles bloß als infektion immer alles plus eins.
Na ja wie ich bereits sagte ich bin dunkelziffer niemand weiß wie hoch die ist wir werden es wahrscheinlich erst in einem halben jahr erfahren oder in zwei jahren oder nie,
ich bin da,
ich bin da relativ entspannt auch inzwischen weil ich das gefühl habe ich kann's jetzt an dem punkt nicht mehr beeinflussen ich habe,
mehr oder weniger alles getan was getan werden musste jetzt mal abgesehen von dem von dem arztbesuch heute,
auf der anderen seite sie haben ja einen termin gegeben ne also das ist so ein bisschen ähm.
Ja ich hätte ich hätte mich gerne schon vor acht tagen testen lassen es gab keinen test wird wahrscheinlich auch keinen mehr geben,
ja so ist es ich habe auch von anderen leuten inzwischen gehört die halt einfach gerungen haben einen test zu bekommen,
ist nichts zu machen dass da ist irgendwie,
ja ich weiß nicht woran das liegt ob da der amtsschimmel wird in deutschland oder ob.
Da ist es halt einfach die überlastung
es gibt da einfach eine eine front mit bedarf von hier muss man ganz unbedingt getestet werden einfach weil man natürlich versucht der ganzen sache detektivisch auf die spur zu kommen um zu schauen so gibt's irgendwas kurzfristiges
sind da potentielle verbreitung die wir noch weiter eindämmen können nur diese eindämmung phase ist irgendwie vorbei.
Ich glaube aus aus dem,
aus dem aus dem ding sind wir raus und wir müssten tatsächlich auch so agieren also,
gut letzten endes letzten endes haben wir den shutdown jetzt und der shutdown ist auch richtig er ist nicht schön aber es ist richtig.
Wie gut er helfen wird wird werden wir sehen.
Aber wahrscheinlich erst in zwei wochen.
Genau und vorher werden dann auch schon die ersten leute schreien dass das ja alles nichts bringt und was soll denn die scheiße.
Ja ja und die wirtschaft und genau.
Die wirtschaft und genau.
Ja also nee so richtig so richtig viel mehr kann ich da jetzt auch nicht mehr zu sagen weil es ist ja auch nichts passiert,
also das letzten endes ich sitze jetzt hier seit seit acht tagen in der erst selbst verordneten und dann mehr oder weniger ärztlich verordneten quarantäne,
und da muss ich jetzt durch seit seit gestern scheint es besser zu werden.
Keine ahnung vielleicht wenn wir uns in der woche nochmal sprechen ist vielleicht vorbei der spuk aber auch dann muss ich jemanden finden der mir sagen kann sie dürfen wieder rausgehen.
Na dann spart ihr mal dein dein atem den du jetzt noch hast ja horst horst und
dann gucken wir mal wenn du nächste woche noch fit bist und wir uns soweit zusammen konsolidiert haben gibt's bei uns auch mit der freakshow weiter dann kann man die ganzen sonstigen aspekte auch nochmal besprechen und,
ja dann kann man das an dieser stelle glaube ich auch abschließen ich werde jetzt hier versuchen zumindest wöchentlich mal eindrücke zu sammeln vielleicht auch öfter vielleicht auch seltener mal gucken wie es weitergeht.
Aber unsere kleine welt unser kleines virus bedroht unsere kleine welt und das muss natürlich begleitet werden okay rudi vielen dank.
Jo tschüss.